i ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
video sono vari j oggi sono ospite in
camera di questo bel ragazzo ha pagato
mille euro e ha un sacco di soldi
l'affitto agitiamo fa con fascia perché
vogliamo vedere insieme sul web e ogni
tanto qualcuno e se qualcuno che si
impara dalla cazzo di cane se qualcuno
che guadagniamo miliardi di euro
allora oggi cerchiamo su google i nostri
nomi vediamo che vediamo che senza
succede innanzitutto la cosa più bella
che compare ricerche correlati correlate
fabio rovati che cazzo ci sono anche
pays des olimpaie io direi di aprire
questa ragazzi perché fa ridere la
leggiamo e ci interessa entrambi
adolescenti giocherelloni primis sui
paperoni italiani di youtube alla
raccogliere della sera che cosa appalto
tipo non mi ricordo quanto tempo fa
oltre mesi fa ha messo un po la faccia
di uno che ne guadagna mezzo della mia
piscina il numero resta sempre lui fa i
geni dal prima di dove l'italiano per
gli iscritti con 3,5 milioni di parquet
dimostrano i suoi numeri 1,5 miliardi di
visualizzazioni che nella premessa di
guadagnare fino a 3 milioni di euro
infatti melo pagato l'affitto per mi
chiedono ma aspetta che dormivano quando
di un botto di soldi
la macchina norma e non ha la patente ma
che cazzo tra via me lo direte croce sul
centro il corriere della sera a non il
corriere della sera poverini magari in
giornali de un tizio un po ebete non il
cuore della terra poverini magari bravi
e lui ha dei problemi come si pronuncia
questa frase caputo affetta ricchi
ricchi ed il pericolo ha detto che
guadagnano che guadagna 3 milioni di
euro perché va fatto ha usato un tool
che non ho capito cos'è che
un'applicazione in applicazione a caso
per trarre il guadagno di youtube
palesemente gustata che va beh non è che
guadagno povero sapete tutti che il
cazzo lo dico a fare ma 3 milioni di
euro
anche noi la decima non a casa che hai
comprato quest'anno
decimati che ci sono anche tra i poveri
adesso ci arriviamo a questo povero e
solo quarto quanto guadagni 746 mila
euro con un incasso mille per mille di
766 euro a pax volgari ma conosciuto per
assistere d'amore nata su youtube con
prima non hai fatto un cazzo da quando
ti sei fidanzato con savi prima non eri
nemmeno quando sei soldi senza le belle
col calcio saponato che c'eri anche te
il mio guadagno del diretto di 5.000 ma
andiamo a fare un calcio tanto una causa
con altre lo vediamo in cinque quindi
mille sono miei
mille sono diviso 5 noi però in quattro
più di mille sono mi avevano indicato un
mix mensa che sono cinque bene che sarà
il grande articolo di diritti e di
diritti garate signori che io andrei più
miratamente andrei a cercare province
vita accanto caso folgorato in tumore
afa vigente o meno fa vj quasi mai
strumia nicky perché non li fai clic
così adesso cioè devi dire almeno che
sono un pezzo di mesi youtubers cancro e
39 gravemente
salve oggi volevo parlare dei cosiddetti
youtubers cancro che nonostante hanno
una comicità pessima hanno una comicità
per anno vitaliano è un optional
vi do anno video pieni di bestemmie
giochi triti e ritriti quelli che
criticando fanno i re il re dei p
tra l'altro le tre i bricchi che tra
l'altro è l'aggettivo più più docile
goleto di bestemmia il e 99 29 09 è un
numero che non la voglia di leggere bene
fermi al secondo il gioco il fatto che
sui luoghi sono scemi quanto la trama
del film porno medio riguardo menzioni
signorno dell'europa da una macera di
carlo ed esse si sposa che è un vendute
abbiamo ottenuto un altro cancro a il
baratto neonato da scegliere se li can
can che forse verrà offerta dal ps forse
verranno aggiunti altri cancro degrado
aggiungete anche sasha
posso capirlo nel power
ma c'è anche la spal morte savi giorni a
parigi roma donna può invece hanno
ragione gli haters perché fa vj hem è un
tossico ed ora che sono entrato nella
commenti posso dire far vj uguale 76 36
son belle 26 gen
poi sono anche biso in parte degli stati
più impatti sia gradito prima come fa vj
il cancro piace ai giovani cosa è uno
slogan gente interni il libro e le ha
rubato 97 minuti della nostra vita
perché noi quando abbiamo organizzato
quando abbiamo registrato all'interno di
abbiamo messo sulle poltrone le ciglie
per tenere la gente ferma e gli abbiamo
risucchiato il dato è collage wired.it
frigerio vero la brutta parentesi coppia
di italiana di più di file credo che non
li bruciasse per niente il culo ma è
anche un po e parigi lo fa con greta
amici non è uno scherzo il cancro del
tour usa vige un cancro cliclo ti prego
0 5 secondi
[Applauso]
vai sulla tua pagina di cody la foto che
c'è la nostra che avevamo fatto il gay o
la prima prima ecco la calda anima si
cento volte meglio tu ace e il centro
diretta che mi piace ma porca vacca mani
che mi sento che possiamo concludere qui
è stata la benna ricerca su i miei non
c'erano come insultato un formato un
postaccio perché non va bene però che
video inizia vissuto
argomento mi piace anche per gli haters
che ci hanno arrestato in tutti questi
anni
vi ricordate mi piace felici non mi
piace depressi matri contratto questo
ruolo per mettere mi piace me l'hanno
regalata ma è bellissimo il vestito il
vino viene anche tu perché allora noi
abbiamo cercato e per due ore insulti a
sasha però non ne abbiamo trovati ben
insultate consultate pietro romeo più
comunque potremo far vj e il piano fitto
[Musica]
d
no
amico